welcome back to middle ground and thank
you to our sponsor dashlane for making
this episode possible
make sure you stick around after the
episode for a special offer from
dashlane
but first here is middle ground free
speech versus censorship
take for example like white supremacy
they don't go away because you censored
them are they going to stop being a
white supremacist
i don't give a [ __ ] i do feel safer
tech platforms play a big part in
facilitating hate today twitter
specifically
has banned a number of different
conservative accounts not just the
president
they can do whatever they want their
private businesses i think that people
should be able to say
whatever they want online however i
think that there should also be
consequences
the president of one of the most
powerful countries in the world
doesn't have access to social media i
think platforms have a right to moderate
content
we really have to be able to discern who
gets a voice and what they're able to
say
we need people in the conservative field
to fight for our right to be
conservative as somebody
who has experienced censorship it ends
up generating these chambers in which
these ideas go completely unchallenged
everybody kind of has to ask themselves
should everybody really be able to say
what they want to say
hi i'm leah thomas i am a writer and the
founder of
intersectional environmentalists which
is an online environmental media hub
hi i'm lawrence i'm a public policy
analyst
for san bernardino county hi i'm bennett
kelly i'm the founder of the internet
law center and
i'm an attorney who represents victims
of online harassment i'm michael
uh i'm 30 i'm conservative and i work in
finance
my name is jerome i'm a political
science student i am 21
and i'm originally from massachusetts
hello i'm joseph i'm an accountant and
i'm working towards my cpa and i'm a
part-time poker player
the prompt is the right
is more censored than the left
i mean we think it's obvious right yeah
i mean
most i mean i'm assuming most of us are
all conservative-ish
you know in that spectrum but i think
that
a lot has happened during the january 6
riots that's why we
see it more and that's why it's more big
of a problem now you know parlor can't
even be on the app store
or you know i mean trump got kicked off
twitter i mean he's the leader of the
free world basically at least for the us
and you know he doesn't even have access
to a social media platform
i don't i think there was twitter which
was left-leaning long before there was
something like parlor
well that's what i'm saying yeah like i
think that these echo chambers that are
created
as a result of censorship are a reaction
they're reactionary they're not
necessarily they wouldn't exist by
themselves if if right
leaning people weren't being sensed
um i guess i disagree because
usually when i think of conservatives i
do think of the party of law and order
so that was definitely something that
trump uh spoke about often like there
are consequences to your actions
maybe more people could read the terms
and conditions and find a platform that
they feel more comfortable with like
charler
4chan but what trump said wasn't really
as bad as what
i've seen other democrats say like us to
not deflect what should be the
appropriate consequences when someone
violates the terms and conditions
i think it should be like a clear
punishment right it shouldn't be
a punishment like especially for like
being kicked off it should be for
everybody
but if if that is the solution that has
to be the solution for everyone
so no name sean king are two of the most
prominent
left-leaning activists that i know of
and they have been repeatedly banned
from twitter
suspended from facebook instagram kicked
them off
and then when it happens to candace
owens and ben sharparo we hear
conservative voices are being but it's
the exact same thing that was happening
on the left
that's now happening on the right so i
think the problem is
you the conservative i don't see you the
conservatives that believe
this rhetoric is being suppressed i
don't think they know
the other side is dealing with the same
thing there's no real history of which i
am aware
of left-leaning creators being
blacklisted the way that guys like alex
jones james woods donald trump have been
yeah
alex jones was on on this journalistic
scene for 30 years
and they erased all 30 years of that how
about the white house youtube channel
they
eliminated all of trump's videos all of
them
do you not see the difference though
because sean king says abolish the
police
and you know say alex jones for example
says
jewish people are the uh owned most of
the property in america
and if you want to deal with property
owners deal primarily with jewish people
in 2015. so obviously there's a stark
difference in rhetoric
and consequence even you call the virus
kung flu
and then a rise in violence against
asian americans who called it kung flu
president did you say it directly though
yes
yes very directly he tweeted it yeah you
tweeted it
there are reasons for the differences
and consequences but i think
if we understand that it's happening
widespread
because i've seen people on the left say
kill cops permanently banned
permanently like done right so i think
we have to take a step back remove
ourselves from the box that we're in and
kind of
okay is it happening over here too
there's ideas that exist
on and offline that are abominable that
i disavow unequivocally but that i
subscribed to when i was younger
you know when i was younger didn't
understand what i was necessarily
looking at didn't have enough worldview
or perspective to know that these were
not
good ideas but because that they were
censored by the forums that i was
espousing them in i never had the
opportunity to have them challenged i
would never have the opportunity to have
a conversation about why these were bad
ideas
there was no purveyance of the
ideological free market and that's
really the only way for these ideas to
go away take for example like white
supremacy people who have those beliefs
those beliefs don't go away when you ban
them from platforms those beliefs don't
go away when you
tell them to shut up those beliefs don't
go away when you punch them in the face
you know or when you revoke their rally
permits but when do we draw the line
because if somebody let's use kung flu
for example what i said earlier let's
say it's alex jones that says oh this is
a chinese virus they brought it here
and then we see a rise in hate crimes
against asian americans
what when do we draw the line because he
would still have the platform yeah i
mean i don't think we should deprive the
people who are actually committing these
crimes of the agency in committing them
right you know like they are doing that
and they frankly would be doing that
regardless of whether or not there was
somebody who was who was using
inflammatory rhetoric online that's
exactly my point when i say these ideas
don't go away
and then you feed that those ideas you
build the anger so for example if you
ban a white supremacist or a huge white
supremacist group from twitter
they're still probably going to be white
supremacists chilling and hanging out
outside of twitter right but it would be
harder for that white supremacist group
on that platform to inflict harm towards
black folks right because then i no
longer i do feel safer
so if i'm being harassed by a white
supremacist group or someone who's
saying that black people don't deserve
to live
i do feel safer as a user are they going
to stop being a white supremacist
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care they
can do whatever they want to do that's
their free speech
however it does make me feel a lot safer
i just think the left is now catching
more up to us and realizing that the
censorship
is happening and then now it's kind of
touching their side too more
and maybe with sean king you see it you
know i've
definitely seen it pick up more in the
past few months on both sides
with the left i mean the example i gave
was from 2014. i know
that's been around for a while you know
when you're looking at the civil rights
movement
and you're looking at the literal
burning down of civil rights
headquarters and things like that my
parents and my grandparents my great
grandparents
in the civil rights movement were
continuously policed and harassed for
their beliefs
violently so jailed for their beliefs so
i find it almost
it's hard for me to compare when civil
rights folks are being imprisoned and
killed for their beliefs
however because a conservative can't use
twitter
i'm supposed to feel bad well i don't
think there's a comparison
what i wonder is whether or not there is
a leftist ideologue
someone who is similar to to alex jones
or or someone like that that was
blackballed from six social media
platforms over the course of yeah right
on the left it doesn't really happen at
all look at look at what they admonish
like
abolish police you know give everybody
health care like
what in that world what in that realm
would be like
you're done you don't need to you know
you're talking about killing people so
we're saying burn it all down this
summer during the riots buildings
but that's not that's still hurt
people's property yeah they build
they save their most savings you know 2
billion damages
as a country we need to say that
violence is bad burning
people's you know stuff is bad and
killing
i think we need to give perspective yeah
it has to be content
yeah because we can't say burning
buildings is bad and not understand the
reason as to why
i don't agree with burning them but we
kind of got to give context to both you
know we can't
we can't just say this is all terrible
you know i don't want to be anecdotal
about this but at the same time
my parents are immigrants you know they
work for everything that they have my
mom
she came from family six and she
didn't have a lot when they came to this
country and each each
of their siblings including my mom they
had to work for everything that they
have
and they made something of themselves so
let's and then we
also have rental properties so if one of
them burned down because of a riot
that's that's our life savings right
there we put a lot of money into that do
you know so i guess let's take it back
to the civil rights movement because
usually i think the
the future sometimes is a better
indicator of what's like morally right
and wrong
i lived about 10 minutes from ferguson
and was there when those buildings were
burning down and it was incredibly
terrifying
but i also remember the business owners
who said i can replace
my windows what i can't replace is a
lost child
so hearing those business owners hearing
them i can talk about them
hypothetically and how i hypothetically
think they might feel
but i also can talk about people who had
their own buildings of course you know
and people people who do say that they
aren't they're on like you know the
black lives matter side of not
necessarily a lot
but at the same time you know like i go
back to business because you know i'm an
accountant and i care about the numbers
and all that stuff
but i care about black lives matter but
yeah we all care about black lives but
also too like
a lot of misinformation was spread about
those rides too with the hands up don't
shoot i
they said that he was facing backwards
and they found out that he wasn't and he
didn't have his hands up we talked about
last year
yeah that's just let's just next they're
spreading the misinformation and then it
also
and also if you'd like to have the
perspective so i was there that day
unfortunately and we can talk about
censorship so after he was killed he was
on the ground for four hours
our radio stations were turned off and
our news stations were turned off
so we didn't have information as to what
was going on which i agree
allowed misinformation to spread however
to say
that so no i'm not agreeing with you but
i'm saying maybe like
know what the people in that community
were faced with before speaking on
something that you don't know it's
terrible that's that's terrible the
censorship of those radio stations is
awful and i think it contributed to a
lot of a lot of misinformation
not just misinformation but pain pain
and
destruction that happened within those
communities because people weren't being
given the information they were entitled
to
yeah you know i think that in itself is
an argument against censorship for sure
tech companies should be allowed to ban
whoever they want
it's a hard one honestly because it is
it whoever just
based on what they deem is wrong like uh
i don't know you know i worked in a
country club once and they had the
strict dress code for employees and even
for members i mean you could
as long as it's illegal right that's the
one caveat
yeah you can't say no jews no yeah
whatever yeah
as long as they they have a set terms
and conditions then
yeah they can ban whoever they want they
shouldn't just ban whoever
you know i think they should be able to
say okay
you're done even if it doesn't
necessarily impede on the terms and
conditions basically
i think what we're having is a free
market response saying they let them do
what they want
and let consumers go where they are but
you have to have a function free market
where people can go somewhere else but
they can't right now though that's the
problem
who who wouldn't be able to go being
removed from the app
on web services basically it's an
anti-trust law kind of thing
because basically they're trying to
create a monopoly between all the social
media
like twitter and facebook yeah i think
that's what i got off of it i've
actually talked to
an owner of one platform who says they
do
more to combat hate speech on a per
person basis than you know some of the
larger entities but they still can't get
picked up on
um you know apple and the google play
that's my
problem the market isn't functioning
properly then
like okay should twitter have the leader
of hezbollah be
on twitter they're listed as a terror
group
by the uh by the eu and the u.s well
they've been still on twitter they've
been sued over that i mean
and they've been sued over that as long
as the tweets aren't promoting
yeah terror violating its terms that's
the yeah that's the yeah
yeah is a political party part of that i
know bin laden is dead but if he were
alive
and he made a twitter and he didn't
tweet anything that violated the terms
of condition to his point wouldn't they
be able to still stay
on the platform right i think that yeah
i mean
i think that should be fair because
i agree they should just ban them yeah
i'm just saying that like if they have a
set guidelines and set rules
they shouldn't like and they follow them
then why would you kick them off in the
first place
i mean if it violates their terms and
conditions i think they're they can
ban whoever they want but i guess just a
hypothetical if all of a sudden they
were like we don't want to see
breastfeeding
so we're going to ban everyone just
because we want to technically they can
because they're a private you know
business entity but i guess morally it
kind of rubs me the wrong way
i want to agree you know but i feel like
if we if i do agree then i feel like i
will be giving
social media and tech companies
far too much importance right you know
people exist without social media i
don't think if you ban somebody that's
like
a morally egregious act i think you'd be
shocked
the number of people especially like my
age and younger who get
their news exclusively from social media
my worry about it
is that the algorithms of these
companies do not
incentivize nuance yeah so a lot of the
time you see
like what trends is what is getting
clicks and a lot of the time that's
controversy
but sometimes too though they
artificially put things that are
trending up there that really
aren't well the problem is it's the it
was advanced
and twitter does that too we don't know
what those algorithms are but there are
suspicions that
they are trying to fuel make conflict
right and conflict creates clicks which
creates comments which creates
engagement
and so in some ways social media is
dividing us as much as it is bringing
people together in this big platform oh
they definitely profit off of the
division too when we talk about the
terms and agreements
it's it's interesting because there's no
there's nothing that says incitement of
violence but
if we do put incitement of violence
then trump didn't really i believe he
didn't incite them because he didn't say
oh
go to the capitol and you know break
down the doors and windows but you have
people on
you know during the black lives matter
movement saying
be be restless oh you know break down
stuff
you know punch a nazi in the face maybe
if you communicated with those people
you would know that a lot of people were
banned there were mass bannings of black
lives matter supporters
since 2014. i personally don't know
anyone who identifies as antifa that's
usually something that that's why i
wanted to say i was like
a talking point on the right but
personally i i know they exist but i
don't know much about them so i would
love for you to
explain so i mean they are getting
banned i personally just might
think so because like i think like maybe
small people like because
i focus on a big social justice account
showing i feel like it's like larger
people who actually said violence like
maxine waters
and i mean chris cuomo don lemon like
chris cuomo's inciting violence he said
like who's
yeah who said who say protests have to
be peaceful yeah i think a good
um a good basis point to like look at
that from is
whether or not someone who goes on
and incites violence who is a politician
is being treated differently than like
someone who goes on inside violence and
is a protest organizer
i think as as a concern yes the
inequitable enforcement of terms and
conditions
is a concern to me on whatever side it's
on and i think back to their various
examples i mean i think one
good one is the covington kids
where a lot of people were putting
things like oh we're going to kill these
kids we're going to feed these kids into
the wood chipper
et cetera et cetera et cetera and they
weren't really getting banned from it
yeah and there was postulation in right
leading circles that it was because
those kids were wearing maga hats cancel
culture is a conversation that has been
happening in liberal spaces as well
maybe we just we don't have like
fox i don't know we have these other
stations but maybe it's just not
reported on a lot however i do
hear so many conversations about cancel
culture forgiveness and accountability
happening in liberal circles as well
spreading lies
should be protected as free speech
my thing here is that i think we have to
be very attentive to who we make
the arbiter of the truth when i think
about lies and like people's lies you
know i think about people's truths you
know people's perspective
people's opinions and you know that
should be protected in that sense
because if you feel something you
believe in something or you have an
opinion on something that is your truth
that is
well maybe to some people it's a lie
maybe to
most of the people it's a lie but that's
your truth and you have the right to say
your truth right
when donald trump was started this
campaign of you know the
election was rigged he actually does
believe that that is his
truth it's it seemed like a lie to a lot
of people on the left there are probably
some people on the right
and but he has the right to say that you
know there's nothing in the constitution
there's no there's no law saying
well the question that begs is who who
says whether it's a lie yeah who decides
it's a lie yeah who's the argument i
think you said
if we allow lies to be spread as part of
like it's free speech
then we have what we have now currently
is i think 500
000 people now died of coronavirus and a
lot of them were
died on account of just lies you know
if you if you wear a mask you know uh
you can't breathe in it you know what
i'm saying you don't you don't have to
social distance
this is a liberal hoax so if we protect
lies in the realm of free speech they
have
real life real-time consequences we
protect people from certain things that
are dangerous
and if i said you know or you know take
this placebo don't
because it'll cure cancer and people did
that and died
that would be dangerous theoretically
you would be liable correct i would be
alive if you use your credentials to say
drink this and it will cure your cancer
and someone did that you would be liable
but would cbs give me your time for a
commercial for that
no can we complain as conservatives that
there's not enough fact checkers that
are on the right
there's snopes there's fact check
they're on the left but there needs to
be someone to take to
scopes is on the left oh yeah how does
the fact check because yeah
the fact that it donates unless i check
facts
yeah well if they're actually a fact
checking well are there any that you all
support that we could like look into or
do you think that's something that like
republicans could try to
that's what i mean that needs to be i
personally think that
i personally think that snopes and
politico are by and large very accurate
yeah i think yeah i mean i think oh i'm
sorry go ahead no
you continue please i think that they're
by and large very accurate but i think
as with
literally any media source i mean you
can't look at there is nothing that will
be the unequivocal truth
right there is nothing you know so you
need to like look at
i know that it's being written from a
place of bi oh i mean sure like
hydrochloxic horror queen is not going
to like
cure you of covid right you know that's
not liberal or conservative that's just
true that's stupid or not it depends it
depends if it's like an opinion and then
it also depends if people like
politicians love throwing out different
statistics and studies and things like
that and as like a little sciency person
i do believe in the scientific method
for the most part and i think that
things should be
tested over and over and over again and
i think providing those
like if a politician is saying a
statistic i think there should be some
sort of fact-checking body however may i
am
totally on board with there being a
fact-checking body that is say 50
republican 50 democrat i think that's
that's totally fine it is political bias
i'm sure in the snopes realm somebody on
the corporate board is liberal
you said the ceo fine but there is true
and untrue and if we begin to link those
two with like political affiliations
then it's dangerous because we have no
realm of truth there are lies that are
harmful lawrence like you were
describing
you know there are a lot of lies that
are harmful and have caused a lot of
harm but giving the government the power
to arbitrate what is and isn't true
i think can also cause a lot of harm
we're far more
uh we should worry far more about the
social sphere
than the governmental sphere because we
have the first amendment yes yeah first
amendment should trump all that's
at least where i stand yeah for the
government right i think for individuals
too well no i mean the first amendment
is about
government restriction on speech so a
lot of people
say i got banned on twitter and my first
remember rights were violent no
that that's a private it's a private
company i get it
some people should not have a platform
i know this kind of goes against my
freedom of speech outlook but like we
were saying before
like i don't want to see hezbollah
having
you know a twitter feed or i don't want
to see you know isis having a twitter
feed
there's definitely a fine line you know
i can't say everyone deserves a platform
there's this thing called the paradox of
tolerance
yeah and i don't know if you guys are
familiar with it but it's essentially
saying that if we're tolerant of
everybody if we give everybody a voice
and we're like all right everything
everybody says is okay as long as you
feel that way
if we're tolerant of everything then
eventually our
tolerance will be snuffed out by people
that are intolerant
i think if they're causing harm so like
what we're all saying
that's when and like serious serious
harm i don't think that we should
encourage that so whether that's like
the
illegal trade of an endangered species
or that's a terrorist organization i
think as a society we should
kind of
the reason why i didn't come forward is
because you know
i think it goes back to cancer culture
in a sense like people who
have been espoused from society because
they did something so wrong is that
cancer culture yeah and you know people
do
bad things and people have committed
like terrible things to
people or someone or you know group of
people but
i think forgiveness should be an element
and people should have their chance to
get back on their platform by i don't
know doing something i i personally
don't know what
the social media companies would do but
it's also like i guess
d platforming versus banning versus just
people
not really wanting to mess with them
anymore and
usually the people who are really vocal
about cancel culture sometimes are
people who they still have their
platform they still have their twitter
they still have their instagram
they're just mad that society has been
like or kelly
we don't like you or like you know what
we don't like if you caused a bunch of
harm to people
the other thing i think about with d
platforming is that you rob
somebody of their opportunity for
absolution so if alex jones were to
decide and for somebody whose platform
is their livelihood
not whose platform or who who has a
livelihood outside of their platform
like jk rowling
when you take that away from them if he
were to suddenly turn around
and he were to say okay the frogs aren't
gay you know and like he was right about
the frogs
controlling the weather he would have no
platform to come and say that
which i consider it to be a problem am i
the only one that's not
um in favor of this whole like
forgiveness you can come back thing
i it depends yeah yeah i'm i'm not
because
i feel like i'm just on the degree yeah
because i feel like
i hate cancer culture i hate the notion
yes that we can essentially exile
somebody
yes but on the same hand i still believe
that consequences are real and if you
have
if you do something that causes lasting
damage then you need lasting
consequences you know if we if somebody
is a manslaughter we put them in jail
for life
if somebody you know does something to
to harm somebody for
over a long period of time you should
not be able to redeem yourself and come
back
to the same place that you were when you
caused that arm you can have a niche
audience like alex jones i'm sure he
still has dedication
but to say that everybody needs to
forgive you oh no because i might not
get through i have to be a consequence
i don't it depends on your religion it
depends on so many different things
but yeah but i think people are able to
come back to some extent but they're
hating on the fact that they're not able
to make as much money i can think of
personal instances
where i had opinions that were heard out
of context that were
rather moderate or something like that
where people had very visceral reactions
and immediately things started to come
apart how dare and i
wish for more of a chance to be heard
and like i want i'm not going to state
these things but they were not anywhere
near the vein of what i was talking
about earlier these were things that
were just kind of unpopular
and right easy to take out of context
and i
wished that i had more of a chance for
people to hear me out
as opposed to kind of react viscerally
from the start i think there's also
personal accountability so for example
if i say something online and a bunch of
people
whether they're my followers especially
if they're people who i know
and trust and they have a really
visceral reaction to it sometimes i
think what's missing on social media is
that moment for self-reflection of like
did i say something that may have hurt
other people
can i get curious about it i might not
agree with that person being hurt
but can i at least empathize with it or
do i want to get back on social media
and say everyone is silencing me so then
i can have
a more niche audience of people who only
agree with me because at this point i
think that
most people just want to feel seen heard
and validated on the left and on the
right and i think there are a lot of
people on the right that do not feel
seen heard and validated i'm not going
to say
that what you all are feeling is a
figment of your imagination i think it's
coming from somewhere and needs to be
attended to
you know you see all these bad things
about happening to you know trump
supporters and like they're getting
their car key or stuff like that and
then my parents are
always like you know maybe you should
just keep it to yourself and that's a
shame because
i thought we lived in a society where we
could talk about
you know different different ideas and
we had that platform to have that free
speech and you know to have a healthy
debate
and so it's kind of i feel
especially my family and on social media
is that they want to put me into
submission to suppress
my voice and my conservative opinions
i don't i i can kind of resonate with
what you said
not necessarily from a family standpoint
but you know from a like
large-scale general you know generally
speaking
when somebody sees like somebody like
like me just
a black man you know like prominent in
their beliefs about like
you know uh the greatness of you know
pre-colonial africa or
you know just loving kente claws and
stuff like that there are presumptions
made
and it obviously doesn't make people
like me feel seen or heard
or understood because you just seen me
and made a bunch of assumptions
you know assumed a bunch of things like
i think we kind of have that problem not
only with social media but just
in general you know there's biases um
it's it's tough
you know it's tough to have any
different opinion for any different
voice
all right you can bump it whatever you
want to do
thank you again to our sponsor dashlane
for making this episode of middle ground
possible
dashlane generates and securely stores
all your passwords and logging
information on every website
so you never have to click forget
password ever again on any device
dashlane lets you store basically
everything passport information
credit card info that autofills banking
info and your wi-fi password all in one
so you always have everything on hand on
any device which is especially great for
travel
speaking of travel there's also a vpn so
you won't be tracked and can access
any content when you're browsing the
internet in other countries for you good
humans out there
go to dashlane.com jubilee to get
dashlane free
on your first device and then use the
code jubilee when you want to upgrade to
premium to get 10
off thank you again to dashlane and
we'll see you next time
you